[Applause]
and take a look at that it was really a
busy night for local law enforcement and
fire departments as they responded to
fires most likely caused by illegal
fireworks so you are able to report them
on the i spy website but does it really
actually help crack down on people like
that who are putting on those backyard
shows victoria sahan joins us now live
from desert breeze park with more
victoria
hey guys here at desert breeze park you
can see the aftermath of the illegal
fireworks that were left over and
although every year there are thousands
of complaints this year the number of
citations given out will shock you
all across the valley fireworks were
heard well after the casinos had their
displays i can see the fireworks coming
up through the trees so they were
not the safe and sane type
resident sydney de long made several
complaints to the eye spy website my
frustration is that i never know you
know whether it's actually being seen by
anybody i'm sure it is but
but i never actually
see any results about it the i-spy
website was launched in 2018 to report
illegal fireworks in neighborhoods and
to lessen the burden of 9-1-1 calls in
2020 there were more than 27 thousand
complaints on the website metro gave out
22 citations and last year there were 21
thousand complaints with just five
citations the total number of citations
given out by metro in the city of las
vegas was 53. that's all
could have done that my block john
archer was another resident concerned
about the damage the illegal fireworks
would cause he shared this picture of a
palm tree by his home that was destroyed
after a fire was put out obviously
prevention is a big thing but at that
point you're trying to put the fires out
not look for who's going to start next
the i spy website is for the whole
county actually just recently got back
the numbers for the complaints for this
year it was just over 14 000 and then i
also heard back from north las vegas
they gave out seven citations again you
are not allowed to let off any fireworks
for the rest of the year fines start at
500 dollars victoria zaha live local now
victoria